everyone I'm Chris pine from the new
movie the finest hours this is the story
of one of the most daring rescues in
u.s. Coast Guard history and I'm Craig
Gillespie as the director of this film
it is a dream to see these epic scenes
play out on the IMAX screen so please
enjoy this exclusive special look of the
finest hours in IMAX 3d
you go up on deck and have a look
chief pick yourself a crew assist that
ship here yes sir
my man and I don't know what he's doing
he's sending you out to die or do I have
the best to get out there I know those
waters pretty good it's your job to go
out right
promise me you'll come back the Coast
Guard they say you gotta go out I don't
see you got to come back in so you think
birdie can get us out past the bar in
this yeah I mean it's just got to be
sure that he doesn't pitch polish that's
all huh the power of the waves on that
bar they can pick you up they content
you in friend over and over again
there's no way to survive that that's
pitchpoling
bring the lines
we've got maybe two three hours
you think I figured that you know the
book better than anybody
I think they'll listen to you listen to
me Papa's men don't like me they might
not like you but don't understand
every fella here wants to live I need
all the help I can get get itself or
watch and look out British oh I need for
men men in the books the rest you are a
[ __ ] light upside down below
communicate with the engine room
you're an embarrassment come on
or show about a mile distance brother 15
degrees to port pass Peter gotta make
attorney degrees under compass to three
time
50 degrees port it has to be 80 degrees
to 310 on compass
I got it I got it
we got everything she's got left